وفي دنيا افاده السلطات المواليه لروسيا
هناك بمقتل مدنيين بقصف اوكراني استهدف
المدينه وبلدات في المقاطعه وقالت ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت باكثر من 70 قذيفه
سبعه احياء سكنيه خمسه منها في مدينه ما
الحق اضرارا ماديه بنحو اربعين من المباني
السكنيه
والمرافق مرافق البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
الى مراسلينا من دنيا دريدي ومن غرب بخموت
حسن شوبكي رانيا نبدا معك ما التفاصيل حول
القصف الاخير الذي طال المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه في
بدايه يعني هذا القصف يعني يمكن القول
جلال انه مستمر وشبه يومي خلال الساعات
الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه طال القصف
الاوكراني وفقا لتسريحات الرسميه الصادره
من قبل السلطات المواليه لروسيا هنا سبعه
احياء سكنيه في مدينه ومقاطعه دانيسك طبعا
جل هذا القصف جاء من نصيب العاصمه تم قصف
خمسه احياء سكنيه فيها ما تسبب بمقتل
مدنيين بجروح ناهيك عن يعني الحاق اضرار
ماديه بنحو 20 مبنى سكني ومباني اخرى
تابعه للبنه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه بشكل
عام وفقا للتصريحات الرسميه الصادره هنا
هناك تقدم للقوات المسلحه الروسيه في
مختلف المحاور على سبيل المثال
هناك تطورات ومعارك داميه تجري في مدينه
افديف كان منذ ايام كانت هناك محاولات ولا
تزال هذه المحاولات مستمره
لمحاصره هذه المدينه التي تعد قد تكون
الاهم من بعد مدينه يعني تحاول القوات
الروسيه محاصرتها من المناطق الشماليه ومن
المناطق الجنوبيه واليوم مصادر عسكريه
مطلعه اعلنت عن ان عن انه تم السيطره على
بلده التي تقع في يعني شمال هذه المدينه
وهي
بحسب هذه التصريحات يعني اخر موقع كانت
تسيطر عليه القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بشكل جزئي في الجناح الشمالي من مدينه
الشمالي الغربي الشرقي من مدينه افديفكا
هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى امس
القائم باعمال رئيس جمهوريه دينيس بوشين
اشار الى ان ايضا مدينه ماريين تستمر
المعارك للسيطره عليها وهناك الجزء الغربي
فقط من هذه المدينه لا يزال تحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وبمجرد السيطره
على هذا الجزء فيمكن الاعلان حسب تعبيره
عن السيطره بشكل كامل على هذه المدينه لو
توجهنا الى مدينه باخمت هنا اود التذكير
بان هذه المدينه محاصره عمليا من كل
الاتجاهات وفقا لتصريحات القائم او مستشار
القائم باعمال رئيس الجمهوريه فضلا عن ذلك
تم الاعلان يعني قبل ايام عن انه نحو 70%
من اراضي باخمد باتت تحت السيطره القوات
المسلحه الروسيه هنا بالطبع الحديث يدور
عن قوات فاجنر حاليا بحسب التصريحات التي
صدرت عن مصادر عسكريه مطلعه تقوم القوات
قوات في داخل المدينه بتطويق ومحاصره
القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقتين اساسيتين
وهي في منطقه الصناعيه لتغيير تقع في شمال
مدينه باخمتو وايضا في الجنوب وذلك بالقرب
من استاذ المدينه الذي يدعى افنجرز حسن
الشوبكي في بخموت ماذا عن الروايه
الاوكرانيه لما يدور في المدينه
[موسيقى]
الروايه الاوكرانيه تقول عكس ما جاء على
بالتفاصيل من الجانب الروسي وتحديدا في
باخ متنالك يبدو تحولات هذه التحولات
تتحدث عنها معاهد للحرب دوليه معهد اي اس
دبليو الامريكي وكذلك الاستخبارات
البريطانيه والاهم من ذلك القاده
العسكريين الذين التقينا عددا منهم في
الايام الماضيه وحتى صباح اليوم هنالك
تاكيدات بان هنالك صد من الطرف القوات
الاوكرانيه لكل الهجمات التي تستهدف
فاسيليفكا وكذلك اريخوف بالاضافه الى
ايفانوفكا كل هذه البلدات في منطقه دوناتس
هنالك صد للهجمات التي تاتي من شمال
وجنوب مدينه باقمت والحديث ايضا عن وقوع
قتله في صفوف القوات الروسيه هذا الحديث
على انسان يعني الجيش الاوكراني وبيان
هيئه الاركان الذي يؤك سقوط 1020 قتيلا
روسيا خلال مواجهات اليوم الماضي بالاضافه
الى ان العدد التراكمي كما اوضح الجيش
الاوكراني وصل العدد التراكمي لخسائر
الروس في هذه الحرب منذ بدئها وصل الى 170
الفا بين قتيل وجريح للقوات الروسيه الاهم
من ذلك ال سي ان ما تحدثت به الاستخبارات
البريطانيه صباح اليوم على درجه كبيره من
الاهميه تقول ان الارتباك والارباك الشديد
الذي حدث للقوات الروسيه وللتوتر الذي
حاصل مع ميليشيا فاجنر تسبب بتوقف جزئي او
عملي للهجوم الذي تشنه في مدينه وهذا الى
حد ما دقيق كما يقول القاده الميدانيون
العسكريون هنا في في باخ متقينا عددا منهم
اكدوا ان جزء كبير من العمليات انتقل الى
اف دي افكا افدي افكا هي تبعد 45 كيلو متر
جنوب مدينه باخمت وهنالك محاوله لمحاصره
من طرف القوات الروسيه لكن للتاكيد يعني
اكد لنا كثير من القاده العسكريين
الاوكرانيين ان ورطه الروس في باخمه ستكون
اصعب في افدي افكا باعتبار ان افدي افكا
تله كبيره والسيطره فيها للاوكرانيين من
الصعب على الروس التقدم في تلك المناطق
وبالاضافه لذلك كان النهر وهو نهر مخمودكا
بالنسبه لباخ موت كان سببا في يعني وضع ما
يشبه الحواجز بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه الى ذلك الامر في يعني يسير
باتجاهات تقول ان كما اكد معهد الحرب
الامريكي اي اس دبليو انه اذاك استطاع اذا
حاولت القوات الروسيه ان تتقدم اكثر عليها
ان تاتي بالكثير من الجنود الى مواقع
الجبهه ومواقع الجبهه الاولى لانها فقدت
الكثير من
من صفوفي افرادها هناك يمكن القول وفقا
لبيان هيئه الاركان انه تم في الليل
الماضيه للقوات الاوكرانيه كما اكدت قصف
موقعين للقياده الروسيه العسكريه بالاضافه
الى مواقع انتشار للافراد وكذلك مستودع
للذخيره
ومنظومات صواريخ موجهه للطائرات بالاضافه
الى تدمير محطتين للحرب الالكترونيه شكرا
لكما حسن الشوبكي من باخ موت ورانيا دريدي
من دونيتسك